but I'm pretty sure even for you like a
like a lot of people probably ask you
for advice like in deems aside from the
guys try to [ __ ] you [ __ ] what do you
mean by that what guys trying to slide
into my DMS and be super creepy and send
me happens to me sometimes I'm pretty
sure happens to you yes yes how do you
[ __ ] deal with that [ __ ] dude like
it's like you know why because here's
the thing I read these comments right
and what I want to say to these dudes
are what the [ __ ] do you think was gonna
happen I owe one I like when you see
this yo what's up beautiful
yo let me tell you something I'm the one
day could treat you right yeah holla
back at me one love hashtag let me tell
you something you [ __ ] fuzzy hair
[ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ] about you and
what the [ __ ] did you think was gonna
happen to man
yes you know I so I have so many
different ways that I've approached this
throughout my Instagram career it is a
great but yeah I don't know Instagram
yeah so it depends on how I'm feeling
that day because sometimes I mean I've
gotten all types of different dams I've
got the guy who's just like I want to
take you to you know my high school
dance and I'm like oh really I don't
even like going to like I'd even like
wait am i you that's like I would you
see my instance stories I've seen you
dance
you see exactly have you seen the way I
do because yeah I'm pretty good you
really don't want me at your dances oh
so you've got those who are just like
okay that's sweet but then you've got
the guy who's like you want this dick
girl and it's like a nude and then
another nude of him from a different
angle and then like a new nude that
maybe he took a few hours ago and the
other ones are like I don't even know
there's all different types but when
guys specifically asked me for nudes and
they're like show me like you know show
me your tits or whatever I just
literally will either send them a really
ugly picture that I find on Google and
like
like cuz because the thing is the way
that Instagram works now is I have to
have my own form of trolling so now
Instagram will say you know maybe
sensitive content so they'll blur out
the picture so they're like oh my god
she responded she sent me a picture and
then they either see like me flipping
them off or they see like my dog's
wiener or like whatever you know and
then it's either they never get mad
they'll either say like oh my god I
didn't think you're gonna respond I'm so
sorry for saying that to you or they go
like oh so funny and you [ __ ] yeah it
also [ __ ] man
it's so odd have you ever gotten a DM
from a really cute guy that were you
like oh [ __ ] oh my god dog you're like
wait hold on a second I know the other
ones a creep you are too but at least
you cute what's ghostly they're never
though it's always the guy where you're
like you had no business sending this DM
you had no business sending me DM saying
like you know I can treat you right like
I'm the reason there hasn't been a man
in your life I'm like you need to relax
like you're saying that definitely
you're not your reason why that's not
the reason my friend thinking like you
[ __ ] dweeb and there's nothing that
pisses me off more because I am like I
wouldn't say I'm like a hardcore
feminist but I definitely am like it's
[ __ ] 2019 woman Rock like you know
let's all empower each other and so when
a guy comes in and they're like you know
you need a man dad I'm like I actually
don't need a man at all so please just
shut the [ __ ] do you know what I [ __ ]
do alright I will [ __ ] [ __ ] I swear
to God I will deadlift your dick to
another universe I will snap that [ __ ]
[ __ ] tighten my glue at the top and
I'll squeeze now Bend that bar dude
[ __ ] all that blood will come on out
[ __ ] send that [ __ ] to orbit get the
[ __ ] out of here can I just I need to
make it creepy DF so I'm just gonna send
them to you and you have to come up with
a good roast no doubt I was like let me
tell you something you [ __ ] foreskin
face [ __ ]
I will slice you up dude if you ever
even come near me I will slice you to a
[ __ ] oblivion daddy's good you force
I wish I was a bad [ __ ] dude if I was a
bad [ __ ] first of all I probably be a
hoe
second of all I'd be a selective home
and third of all do it when I reject
somebody I will crush their [ __ ]
spirit day yes I will make sure you
regret you were ever born the best DM I
ever got was from like no joke ok this
person basically goes like hey baby girl
like I love following you on Instagram
you're so bad that it I can click on
this person's profile he's 11 oh he is
11 and he's bruising it was so Q I can
even be mad because it was just like him
in the mirror like grew up in the
suburbs like in his look nice little
house and he's like I really 10 I would
yeah I would find his last name find him
on Facebook cuz he definitely has a
Facebook for sure and I was saying to
his parents I know that's a good idea I
could never find my friend Gina does
that so she finds like these little kids
that [ __ ] first of all like demean
women oh they say whatever they're 12 13
years old they send it to their parents
and their [ __ ] parents what their
phone because they these parents don't
know how these kids talk to women yeah
yeah I mean like first of all number one
like I'm really close to my mom like I I
talk to my mom like almost every day
yeah so I grew up with that really tight
relationship so you know a lot of the
stuff that I feel like even when I was
younger when when you know a lot of the
guy friends about yo y'all [ __ ] them
I always feel a little weird about it
yeah so you know and this is like during
the time when I'm super young I just
want to be a part of the group so you
know I would be involved with that type
of [ __ ] I'm not saying that what I'm in
in Miami and I see a fat ass I'm like
god of course I'm still a dude but I
know would I ever say that to a woman
like absolutely not right in my mind I'm
like they're just there am I not
supposed to look what am I supposed to
do but I cover my face but look at those
legs
because they say [ __ ] like this like you
don't know what I'd do with that exactly
you wouldn't know what you do this right
I would snap your dick I would break it
I would Kegel me I say mess up things
were like if it were up to me like I
would literally chop off their Weiner
and then like peel off the skin and then
cut it into little sausage pieces and
feed it
yeah you you could without me without I
think you're good without good okay it's
like the weirdest thing that I feel you
maybe I may be old you fry it maybe in
the thirst of ice cream on top of it
yeah why the [ __ ] not I'm getting hairy
what the [ __ ] what you just yeah I don't
know man like these kids are kind of
weird but I it's not even just this
generation the guys have been doing it
for a minute yeah for a long time
they're just emulating like some of
these scumbags that they see like online
is [ __ ] and these dudes too they they
had like this weird habit of telling
people yo I smashed this chick yo this
girl that girl and it's like yell bro
first of all I'm your friend and I know
you got rejected 38 times before you
found the one drug ugly [ __ ] that would
[ __ ] oh my god right truth yes so it's
not like you're this [ __ ] suave dude
that's just [ __ ] taking down girls
you're that [ __ ] creep that got
rejected X amount of times and then
finally somebody was dumb enough to say
yes so don't and that's not how they
tell the story no no no they make it
seem like they are Rico suave and they
just finished their way because they're
so charming and whatever I did whatever
yeah yeah 1,000% it's very cringy and I
have done my best and I knew so many
guys like that like especially when I
lived back in the bay and now I just
like make it a point to avoid anybody
like the play because you can sense it
right away like based off the way that
they which is so unfortunate that I'm
saying that because then somebody might
say the same thing about me but you can
tell by the post that they put on
Instagram or like how [ __ ] dare you
Jasmine [ __ ] fast badass picture
I can't even say cuz so fast
dude there are times to like because I
follow my friends a lot you know I don't
follow a lot of like women I think I
feel like because it's so abundant on
Instagram you kind of get desensitized
to everything alright totally yeah and
so like it's just like I said I get it
like I'm not say number one like when I
see her pictures I'm like that's nice
ass of course she has a very nice
derriere oh thank you and I'm going to
appreciate cuz I'm an ass man but then
it gets to that point to where like
people are like whoa have you seen this
girl this girl I'm like not
really I don't really know her right at
this point and if you haven't lived in
LA there's a lot of it's just an
abundance at this yeah so you do really
do get desensitized yeah after a while
but sometimes like I flipped on my first
why'd you fall in that is Mary okay with
you following this girl yeah you know I
mean this is [ __ ] photo that I wanted
to recreate so bad when I was Hawaii but
I didn't do it was like you won the beat
in your ass which one you're talking
about told me you were going to I would
also point in your life recreate one of
my pictures I kind of want to gain
eighty pounds again just so I could do
because it's funny or what I'm bigger I
mean cuz like if I cuz if I get buff and
I do it then it's just like Oh what are
you trying to show off your muscles
rating like the fat a guy doing it it
made me laugh oh my god when you would
put okay there are so many times that I
would be in a public location like a
phone you on the wall with your ass
crack out what you open if you calm it's
like dude I was with my family I strike
back you took the [ __ ] risk when you
hit that follow button alright that's
that's the risk you literally i but for
me it was so funny because i was like
smiling while zooming in and then
realizing like oh [ __ ] i'm at a grocery
people are so funny too because every
time I do that I lose like a thousand
guys really but then I'll gain like
2,000 oh yeah so it's like you [ __ ]
like homophobic [ __ ] people
weird on social media I didn't realize
that like people actually were touchy
about that stuff until I think I'd
posted I had post about Thanksgiving and
how I don't like I don't really
celebrate our acknowledge it because
it's a pretty [ __ ] terrible day don't
we rock I'll eat the food like I'm not
like against it but I don't post like
I'm so thankful for my family I just
don't yeah and I'd post about why and so
many people were so offended they were
just like why would you turn it into
this and that I'm like well literally
like people got slaughtered that day so
you know but people were so offended and
people started following me and
then I'd like it posted from politics
ones I'd post about gay rights once and
people you really see like just how much
that can offend or affect people and
it's so interesting because to me
regardless I'm always like okay that's
your opinion
yeah of anything you know and I may not
agree with it and you might be a [ __ ]
terrible person for it but I'm not gonna
like destroy your character but you
don't like Thanksgiving Jessie did you
ain't never been to my Thanksgiving rod
hook I couldn't a [ __ ] I don't
really say I'm Kramer I was born on the
Korean so eat the food no I'll go and
I'll eat let me take some [ __ ] cuz you
like Thanksgiving all right
if you eatin a [ __ ] turkey that
means you like thanks even you
celebrated that [ __ ] Turkey huh you
ain't had my turkey though my take is
[ __ ] good my [ __ ] cookies potatoes
and gravy and stuffing okay and that's
how it gets all do the booty huh good
how why why don't you I genuinely think
Turkey [ __ ] around your Mexican eyes at
me do you understand me American dammit
I don't give a [ __ ] what you are alright
my [ __ ] Puerto Rican [ __ ] you
understand me what's your turkey like
David that's important Rican food right
now blackness busting the [ __ ] rope
of your hair I don't give up anyways my
turkey I actually
spatchcock it and then I'd assembly what
does that even mean
spatchcock well I so you so special hugs
where you